[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
March 2nd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
it's not just single-family homes that
saw an explosion in prices as the
country emerged from the pandemic new
leases on apartments also increased but
now we're seeing a softening of the
rental market Wall Street Journal
housing reporter Will Parker joins us
with details hey well thanks very much
for being with us thanks for having me
so will we saw a steep run up in rents
in the aftermath of the pandemic how
much have they come down Reds have come
down about 3.5 percent since the summer
at least according to one measurement
and that's a reprieve for renters but
it's important to keep in mind just how
much rents Rose directly before that you
had rents Rising something like 25
percent in less than two years before we
started to see a little bit of a cooling
more recently all right so they've come
down a bit but aren't Rises and falls
and rents normal they are and it is also
somewhat seasonal but there's a lot more
going on here right now than just
seasonal change there's two factors
really on the supply side there's a lot
of new apartments coming on the market
these are new construction buildings and
that creates more competition among
landlords for renters and on the demand
side you also have people who are
getting really pinched by these higher
prices and making decisions to either
move home or move in with family and
that also leads to more empty apartments
and may prompt some landlords to bring
down their asking rents yeah what are
these declines in rents tell us about
the personal finances of tenants I think
it's unquestionable that after a 25
percent increase in rents in which there
was not a commensurate increase in Wages
that's going to have a significant
effect on people's financial decision
and I think it comes from a couple of
sides on the one hand a lot of young
people may be putting off decisions to
rent their first apartment lengthening
their stay with friends and family and
then there may be also some renters and
some survey data suggests this is
happening who are making the decision to
not renew leases to move in with more
people or with family because prices
have simply become higher than what
their incomes can support you know young
people putting off renting an apartment
sounds a bit like what we're seeing
among home sales it does follow what
we're seeing with home sales prices
climbed really high in that market
mortgage interest rates of course made
affordability even worse and what you're
seeing in rent is a similar Dynamic of
prices rising and people having to put
off those kind of decisions about their
housing so where are we seeing the most
pronounced declines in rents so we're
seeing rents come down most in some of
the places where they really boomed with
the start of the pandemic that includes
Phoenix and Las Vegas which were places
that sort of swelled with newcomers many
of whom were from California where
incomes are higher that kind of
migration cooled down somewhat more
recently and so rents I think are coming
back a bit with that change were there
any other towns that saw a cooling and
migration so some of these towns that
people moved to in large numbers during
the pandemic these so-called Zoom towns
where people could work remotely and do
everything on Zoom instead of at the
office these places are not seeing quite
as much migration as they were a year or
two ago and so that lesser demand from
that group of people is probably
affecting what rents landlords are
reasonably going to be able to get in
those places all right so this average
3.5 percent decline there's some relief
there for renters but what are these
declines in rents likely to mean for the
rental market going forward I think the
spring will be a big tell for the rental
market
if you see prices continue to decline in
the months where you expect them to pop
back up I think it means that a more
significant correction is happening with
rents but if they stabilize I think it
means unfortunately for renters that
they really can't expect rents to go
down much more than what they already
have since last summer and there's not
going to be much of a reset in reality
for affordability
and even with a three and a half percent
decline in new lease rents rents are
still a lot higher than they were before
the pandemic and a lot of American
cities some very large ones to rents and
Tampa and in Miami Florida was a big
growth area those rents are 30 35
percent higher than they were in 2020.
so a couple of points of decline doesn't
really make much of a dent and that
incredible increase that we just saw by
the way what does new lease mean new
lease rents are what renters pay at the
beginning of a new apartment lease so
it's a different measurement than asking
the entire population of renters what
they're paying at a given time right
because people are in the middle of
leases this is simply looking at the
small portion of the renter population
that is going out and looking for an
apartment right now and what they will
pay for that new apartment versus what
they would have in the past all right
that's Wall Street Journal reporter Will
Parker will thanks for being with us
thank you and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]
thank you